okay so you can see even in the
the triangle get up
from a marshall point of view you start
doing weird things
but they don't feel weird to you because
you don't know the martial context you
can't
imagine all the things that an aggressor
can do to you
so you don't know when you deviate from
the form
that you are partially vulnerable
there's no context for your movement
and the only thing you have to rely on
is your capacity
to replicate the teacher's form
but that's nearly impossible
it's it's and i'm not talking about your
body is different from your teacher's
body
that's that's not what it is that you
see
the technique from the ego tripartite
it is constantly being interpreted
and placed in your own egocentric
context so
it's placed in the context that
redefines
the eye and so
the art is outside of the ego tripartite
so that
deviation is always that it's always a
deviation
so you can either take
decades of
entering yourself into sparring context
where you realize
oh god my head's too low or oh
man i'm i'm heel weighted or oh
i shouldn't be going forward right now
um
or you could just replicate the
teacher's
technique more purely less through your
ego tripod
but i find a happy medium between
understanding the martial context
it's very important that you understand
the martial context because
you're going to fill in the blank just
automatically you always will
you will fill in that blank that context
without the marshall experience it's
going to be wrong
it's going to be a deviation from the
get-go anyways it's going to be wrong
so let's look at the
tessavaki from yesterday okay let's look
at it
marshally and the first thing to note
is aikido kihon waza is not
a one-to-one
training application ratio
meaning a guy that grabs my wrist
does not deserve for me to kill him by
feloniously battering his head with the
planet
it is a training device and within the
training device
you have some martial
strategies and tactics not all that you
will need
but some and if you don't have those
some
you will never be able to do the art
martial it won't happen so we have to
understand
this sum um
this what i'm talking about here is not
the totality of what these
training drills teach you we're just
looking at the marshall side of things
so yesterday um we had the ikea adhesion
part
you need a nike adhesion skill you need
the internal skills
so you are working on that you do have
an angle cancellation on that arm you
have to understand
basic concepts of checking the guy out
through diagonals that cut through his
height width and depth
and then you also have this notion of
i'm going to control from two
points okay i want to know how wherever
i'm touching i'm controlling the guy
from two points
by controlling i mean that i am
affecting his
uh the relationship between his center
of gravity his line of gravity and his
base of support
i i am manipulating it okay
um we're now going to go
to kata dodi but it's going to be the
same
okay and we're going to be able to
understand one more thing from
kosadori there there is a notion that i
work
up the body from outside
to the spine line this is a very common
strategy
in martial arts so i'm passing
all this in front here passive that's
what i want
so when you're doing closer doing
it's just one arm and pass
his head to the other arm
when you're doing katahdin you're to
have that same angle of cancellation
you're going to have the same height and
adhesion which you'll passing it from
one arm to the other arm to the head
that's what you want
oh this is
[Music]
yes
okay let's go all right so of course
the question was ask her are you are you
are you pulling him
no you're not calling him even though
he's gripping
i'm not using his script so i'm not
using this
picture move that he has here and the
width of my hand to make him move
so he can he can open his hand and
you can do it that's the eye
the internal aspect okay i have to be
able to adhere cause this adhesion
and it was that that lets me
get the two points those two points are
controlling him
so i don't have to do this arm
manipulation
if i am required to do the arm
that means i need to control his arms
combatively
and that only makes sense to somebody
who does not train combatively
because when you do you'll find out
that is extremely hard to do to get
someone's arm
okay every new um
law enforcement officer i ever trained
always thinks it's possible
and they realize after a few arrest
attempts
it's not possible or you guys in your
name was uh
are you just killing arm bars like this
and figure fours and kimuras no no
you're
not right so it's as simple as
he's he's trying to manipulate my arm
some way right and
just people just pull out their arm
so when you are grip dependent
you are arm dependent and your martial
viability is going way down
and that's not the strategy the strategy
as i said is to manipulate the
relationship between his center of
gravity his line of gravity and his base
of support
not to manipulate his arm
so when we go to this technique
this is the same thing you have to have
that ik adhesion there
you're not thrift dependent
but on the other arm here you don't have
it
at all you don't you don't grab them
you're doing the same life
adhesion
so i deletion adhesions
and then i go back to the same thing
just two points of control
but not grabbing not opening
from back here
that was it you worked the drone
girl
this part here is another thing you're
trying to learn
but it's not that first strategy
how do i clear the stuff between him and
me
what stuff his limbs how do i get past
his limbs
and get to spinal control okay
try it again okay so uh again
this is i'm moving one
two head one two head
one two head okay that's that's the idea
so that means that when i bring him here
this hand is going to continue him going
with that adhesion
it's not here he stopped and then
i go behind him because again
if you fought people you'd realize
going this is not the opening the 12
6 line is not the opening several things
happen
okay either forget the wrist grab
because it was never about a wrist
ground but i have a guy
aggressive well he's going that way
and i'm going that way we're going to
pass each other
okay or he's going that way
i don't necessarily pass him but now
i'm going to be fighting his forward
progress okay and again
if you don't ever fight you don't
realize you can't just grab people from
the back of their body and chuck them
down
okay
so you want to look for
one more adhesion and now partially
you've set up the eevee angle
which is not at the 12 6 line but
at the 3 9 line okay
so interest yourself with setting up
this three
nine line and then you'll probably
interest yourself with
actually doing the first marshall tactic
pass him to the other hand as opposed to
check him and then you're going to do
this he should still be going
forward he goes forward
into the technique
going forward
try to get that three-nine line for your
entry
the next marshall skill
is once i've passed his uh spinal
spinal control to my other hand
is how to manipulate
the distal end of the lever so it's
distal because it's far from his center
of gravity okay
but how to manipulate the distal animal
level
in a way concentric with the art so
it's gotta abide by new yong theory and
non-contestation
okay so because you have this forward
progress to him
when you do this little circle here
his forward progress
is going to start creating
um an adhesion on my hand
as it's doing a kind of centripetal um
pattern in this spiral okay so
it's not that i tilt his spine
it's that i'm going to do this
little thing like this you see
i want to feel his centrifugal energy
harmonizing or being capitalized upon
with my centripetal energy do you get
that
so that that makes this one wrong
right and that also
makes these tilting things right
and again if you spar you realize
oh i tilted the guy but i can't do
anything with it you know or
i can't tilt the guy because he just let
go of the arm control that i had
things like that okay so i'm doing the
first
like adhesion arm pass final control
and getting his
forward process to generate
an integration with my centripetal
energy okay
so one two four
move forward
[Music]
and that way this arm is does not become
so mechanically a slave to the arm
manipulation
okay because it's not really the major
engine
in that kazushi you see
[Music]
and again don't think this is what i do
when there's an arm grab don't think
this is what i do when i pass the arm
it's just a skill it's a totally unique
skill set
in the same drill
so i'm going to work on this and now
i'm going to work on this
i'm going to work on that too
let's go back by step so we'll leave the
head control off for a second
let's just look at this arms okay so
his he has the um
hinge at the elbow and he and then he
has his ball socket joint
at his shoulder okay and so
uh when when you're below the elbow
and you try to control him it's very
easy for him
to open his arm you see he absorbs the
energy that you had checking him
and then the same thing when i go uh
above the elbow but i'm on top of his
arm the ball and socket joint
doesn't give me the control i want so
when i control
his body i'm going to control it here
above the elbow making that joint
irrelevant to what i'm doing
and then uh near the ball and socket
joint
so that as it as it moves all around
it's i can stay with it
you see it doesn't immediately go
underneath me
so here and then in the same way as on
the neck control
i'm using the
harmonization i'm doing between his
centrifugal energy and my centripetal
energy that's making that stuck on there
so they're not independent the two of
the two of them
are what's moving okay so don't let that
arm go dead
all right anytime i'm down below here
you're dependent upon the aikido culture
of some weirdo that keeps his hand
stuck to yours which is not a nike
adhesion that
is a masquerade of a traditional
historical internal aspect this
keeps his hand there and and you tell
him some stupid thing like you know
he's protecting himself it's like
there's all kinds of ways of protecting
yourself rather than sticking yourself
to me
as the attacker as a defender okay so
above near the ball and soccer joint
okay
um because now the more that i'm not
doing that
the more dependent i am on that arm or
on that stupid training culture
and then the less martial my technique
is going to be
meaning these aspects i will not be able
to bring
outside of the forms training and into
more live environments
so you're going to see whether you were
armed dependent or not as we move up to
ski
okay so he's gonna do uh jodonsky
boom okay and i have to do
the arm pops the arm pops
and then that part is exactly the same
so
here comes his ski boom
[Music]
reach out
this isn't a self-defense technique this
guy
punching me that's not what's happening
but you're taking away your grip
dependency
you never started with the grip depend
with the grip
so he goes boom there's that not three
[Music]
lines
okay so now we're
we'll work on those skills uh
outside of that cultivation environment
okay
so let's say um i don't disaggress i'll
find it
okay so here he's in that
so here is my pass that i want
you see oh this arm is going to pause
pause
and then i'm going to do that little
circle
okay so we're here home pass this little
[Music]
circle
uh
[Music]
okay let's go okay okay
so again you're just you're not you're
just drilling
you're still just drilling you're still
um this concept of get
see all this stuff get get rid of it and
uh start affecting that relationship
center driving line of driving basis for
okay that's all you're doing so
he he did that i'm i'm weaving outside
right so pop
you're you're out here like this okay so
the first time
my hand happened to be on on the inside
you see
so i'm gonna use the two hands to keep
him going
so it's not it's not a pairing and then
i try to get back here
because you can't get back there as you
sing you can't get back there
okay so uh as we go
this is going like that but everything
can shrink now
as as he has way more energy than in the
keyhole
okay everything kind of shrinks but
everything stays the same
in principle so boom and i know and now
i will not be able to do the head
manipulation of idiomy nugget because he
has no more forward progress
okay so your your timing is here
he has to be going that way for me to
use my centripetal
energy which is why i can't stop him
i need him to go that way and then the
eye could he should make sure he goes
that way
and he's casting him boom right here
and that's the opening that the ending
doesn't matter
sometimes uh i am just was here
he came that way brought behind her i
know this is me
you just go right to the second part
okay
but you'll see that this this skill set
boom starts to open up that opening
there
so in this drill i just
i want to start learning the skill less
and less
in a structured way so you're going to
um
i'll be okay okay and
don't take the first one let happen
okay so i'm gonna keep doing
my aggression and so you see he didn't
keep me going forward
okay so let's see here
he's keeping this aggression right
don't don't worry if you get tagged
don't worry don't worry that's not a big
deal in this drill
okay but you don't have to get tapped
just keep working
and eventually you'll feel it boom
keep going boom keep going
boom
[Music]
and you'll find it on the shiro tank on
the yoshido tank
[Music]
straighter straighter keep going
get on the inside get on the inside good
inside
[Music]
boom boom boom
okay kind of work the drill like that
you're getting a little bit of
desensitization to um
it's really up to you okay to keep the
energy frame okay all right
remember i'm trying to drill a marshall
tactic
i'm not fighting the guy right so
he has to set up he has to uh
um do something that i would be on the
outside and hence pass
past the arm and then find the head okay
so if if he's going to start going on
the end um there you go
or he's not penetrating it at all
do you get it so your uke has to set up
the drill
just like in kihon waza was
prescribed set up the drum
so the same thing when i'm here i i'm
gonna be okay
i'm not gonna go oh you would never
i'll tell you right now never pass that
arm
aggress me okay
so the drill for uke is he keeps setting
that
up come on there it is
so you see i could not stop
so that he keeps getting it in a more
fluid starting point
so i keep going
and he wants to relax tighten his
movement
shrink the windows for the timing
you're a lot of fighting a lot of
contestation
so go this is what that felt like keep
going that's
straight dude i'm gonna if you're gonna
change the drill i'm gonna change your
room
okay you got it okay so
one straight you're here keep going
you see there's no non-contestation of
your jiu-jitsu
so you feel that business so
always yielding yielding and
hearing find that
don't peel on the straight line over he
goes
so yield on the spiral diagonals spiral
boom there's gonna be one string human
boom there it is
okay so fix yourself okay i'll take you
off the mat
okay so what what we're seeing now is
he's gone
and you're starting to go like this okay
but
you're in front of the guy now this is
not the technique
he's supposed to be over there so that i
can do my potential energy
he's going forward
your problem if you give me the udemy
tencon version of
me is again you filled in the blank
okay uh the tencon
is not where the kazushi happens this
same thing is happening here
okay it's not uh that i'm going like
this and then he's going down
that's not what's happening in the ten
conversion
okay so i'm doing the first one
right and there's all this weight
you see it can easily happen so the way
he starts to fall here i can't bring him
back that way
the weight falls here and i non-contest
right so he give me some weight here and
i move out
[Music]
it's not this streamlined
okay so in this drill though we're not
doing the 10 conversion so let it go
forget it he's going he's penetrating
boom i'm on the straight line hey fix
myself get some angles
oh there it is that's it
get some angles that's it
the arm past the harmful that's it
that should be my drill if you're
finding yourself drinking
you're doing it wrong there you go